[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf uns marietta slomka
guten abend tag der deutschen einheit
den angela merkel heute dazu nutzte eine
selten persönliche rede zu halten sie
sprach was sie sonst kaum wehtut
ausdrücklich über sich und dürfte mit
der kritik die sie an westdeutschen
deutungshoheit 'nen formulierte vielen
ostdeutschen aus dem herzen gesprochen
haben dazu kommen im laufe der sendung
noch ausführlich wenden uns aber erstmal
den aktuellen bemühungen zu für dieses
vereinigte deutschland eine neue
regierung zu finden einschließlich
merkel nachfolge da gab es ja heute
einen ganzen gesprächs reihen die letzte
runde ging erst vor einer knappen halben
stunde auseinander
andreas huppert und las bohnsack
berichten
das gebäude in berlins mitte eher
funktional unscheinbar den auffällig ein
pulk journalisten mehr nicht da kann es
schon mal passieren dass die die
eingeladen sind kurzfristig die
orientierung verlieren
den anfang an diesem sondierung sonntag
machen fdp und spd alles erinnert ein
bisschen an speed dating schnell soll es
gehen aber dennoch gründlich drum prüfe
wer sich für vier jahre bindet nach gut
zwei stunden ein erstes nüchternes fazit
das waren sehr konstruktive gespräche
sehr stark in der sache orientiert wir
sind uns dass es deutlich geworden
bewusst dass es große herausforderung
gibt die vor diesem land liegen nach 16
jahren merkel klar ist dass es klappen
gibt aber klar ist auch dass wir
entschlossen sind eine
reform regierung zu bilden die unser
land nach vorne bringt was die liberalen
damit meinen sagen sie eher am rande und
das geht weit über das hinaus womit die
fdp in den wahlkampf gezogen ist für
eine reformregierung braucht es mehr als
steuersenkungen und die förderung des
mittelstands der klimawandel aber auch
die fragen der demokratischen
entwicklung in unserem land der
sicherung der sozialsysteme ich glaube
der handlungsdruck ist größer geworden
diesen handlungsdruck spüren auch die
grünen und wollen den unbedingt mit
einer ampelkoalition in politik umsetzen
die probleme warten nicht stichwort
klimakrise stichwort die verunsicherung
in der gesellschaft raus aus der
pandemie alles das schreit nach einer
starken regierung und so fällt das
zweite partner findungs gespräch heute
das von spd und grünen hörbar
harmonische aus an den beiden soll eine
ampel nicht scheitern
wir haben auch bei der spd eine
bereitschaft gefunden und festgestellt
tatsächlich noch einmal neu zu starten
eine dynamik zu entfachen die dann ja
auch die liegengebliebenen probleme
vielleicht lösen kann
aus berlin-mitte geht es nach schöneberg
hier treffen sich fdp und die union
jamaika ist seine einzige chance aufs
kanzleramt doch eine politische
überlebensgarantie hat armin laschet nur
für die zeit der verhandlungen
ich glaube das ist ganz normales dass
sich personalfragen dann auch am ende
einer inhaltlichen verhandlung stellen
alles andere wäre ja verwunderlich vor
allem wenn man wahlergebnisse kennt noch
wird über personal nicht gesprochen der
regierungsanspruch aber bleibt
ein gemeinsames verständnis in diesem
gespräch geschaffen dass etwas neues
entstehen muss weil die herausforderung
so groß sind dass auch nur mit neuen
ansätzen diese großen aufgaben für die
zukunft deutschlands bewältigt werden
können für heute ist zwar das speed
dating in sachen regierungsbildung
vorbei die endgültige partnerfindung
aber noch lange nicht
theo koll steht für uns auf dem euref
campus in berlin schöneberg wo union und
fdp bis gerade eben gepackt haben t
heute nachmittag nach dem treffen von
fdp und spd da wirkten die
generalsekretäre na ja etwas verkrampft
war das jetzt eben nach der runde von
fdp und union herzlicher
nun es geht ja für alle gespräche
höchste vertraulichkeit aber die
zwischentöne waren hier deutlich
zugeneigt der cdu generalsekretär sprach
von großem vertrauen der
csu-generalsekretär sogar von einem
guten abend der lust auf mehr macht bei
spd und fdp war es in der tat zwar auch
konstruktiv aber erkennbar nüchtern für
christian lindner und die fdp gilt
natürlich weiterhin dass sie am liebsten
eine jamaika regierung mit der union
bilden würden und natürlich schauen sie
täglich ratloser auf den zustand der
union und auch auf die massive
innerparteiliche kritiker nami laschet
lindner meinte heute morgen die union
müsse klären ob sie wirklich eine
regierung führen will sein
generalsekretär der sagte eben die
diskussion mache für ihn aber sein und
für seinen jamaika interesse keinen
unterschied
spd und grüne tun sich jedenfalls
insgesamt mutmaßlich leichter
ja das ist erklärtermaßen für beide die
jeweilige lieblings verbindung mit
vielen inhaltlichen schnittmengen bei
sozialen themen mindestlohn 12 euro
einführung einer kindergrundsicherung
besser entlohnung von pflegekräften da
sind sich beide parteien sehr schnell
einig und natürlich auch beim tempolimit
aber die grünen haben auch noch das alte
schröder wort von koch und kellner in
den genen und sie wissen dass olaf
scholz ein harter und unangenehmer
verhandler sein kann also die ich habe
gehört die grünen haben sich sogar schon
in hamburg erkundigt wo die partei ja
nicht nur gute erfahrungen mit dem
damaligen ersten bürgermeister olaf
scholz gemacht hat also es wäre ein
trugschluss wenn die spd glaubt dass die
grünen es ihnen leicht machen würden in
jedem fall hat der spd-generalsekretär
am abend schon verkündet man sei jetzt
fertig und könnte zu dreier gesprächen
übergehen ich bin auch weiter beobachten
danke theo nach berlin
während in berlin die einen darum ringen
zu irgendeiner form von einheit zu
finden fanden in halle heute die
feierlichkeiten zum tag der deutschen
einheit statt sie wurden diesmal vom
bundesland sachsen anhalt ausgerichtet
und so versammelte sich in halle alles
was in dieser republik rang und namen
hat angefangen vom ökumenischen
gottesdienst in der paulus-kirche bis zu
einer abendlichen drohnen show
sachsen-anhalts ministerpräsident reiner
haseloff erinnerte daran wie besonders
es war dass diese revolution
1989 friedlich verlief ohne
blutvergießen
höhepunkt des tages war aber zweifellos
die rede der bundeskanzlerin die so
überraschend persönlich war und
vielleicht erahnen lässt was von frau
merkel noch so zu hören sein wird wenn
sie nicht mehr die zwänge ihres amtes
verspürt andreas weise berichtet
festakt zum tag der deutschen einheit in
halle niemand ahnt wohl dass angela
merkel eine solche rede hält kanzlerin
kritisiert offen den umgang vieler im
westen mit den biographien der
ehemaligen ddr bürger auch hier
vereinigen da blitzte einen moment lang
durch dass sie keine geborene sondern
eine angelernte bundesdeutsche und
europäerin ist zitat ende
keine geborene sondern angelernte
bundesdeutsche keine geborene sondern
angelernte europäer gibt es zwei sorten
von bundesdeutschen und europäer das
original und die angelernten die ihre
zugehörig jede möglichkeit jeden tag
aufs neue beweisen müssen selbst die
cdu-nahe konrad-adenauer-stiftung
bekommt nach einem seitenhieb für einen
text gewissen
ich zitiere
sie die als 35 jährige mit dem ballast
ihrer ddr biografie in den wende tagen
zur cdu kam konnte natürlich kein von
der pike auf spezialisiertes cdu
gewechselt bundesrepublikanischer
prägung sein zitat ende
die ddr biografie also eine persönliche
lebensgeschichte von in meinem fall 35
jahren in einem staat der diktatur und
repression ballast erzähle dieses leben
von der deutschen einheit nicht wirklich
ballast eben bestenfalls zum gewichts
ausgleich tauglich im grunde aber als
unnütze last abzuwerfen ganz gleich
welche guten und schlechten erfahrungen
man mit brachte ballast bis heute davon
bin ich überzeugt wird zu wenig gesehen
dass die wiedervereinigung für die
allermeisten menschen in westdeutschland
im wesentlichen bedeutete dass es
weiterging viel zuvor
während sich für uns ostdeutsche fast
alles veränderte
stehende ovationen nach ihrer vielleicht
letzten großen rede einer rede die nicht
nur im saal parteiübergreifend für
erstaunen aber auch nachdenken sorgt
merkel warb auch dafür dass menschen in
ost und west mehr übereinander erfahren
sollten sich mehr füreinander
interessieren sollten wörtlich sagte sie
seid neugierig aufeinander erzählt
einander euro geschichten und haltet
unterschiede aus am meisten geschieht
das wohl in den grenzregionen da wo ost
und westdeutsche entlang der mauer
lebten und sich nach dem mauerfall
sofort und viel begegnet wie vereinigt
ist man dort heute eine reportage dazu
von melanie haack und florian kock
wo markus schneider seine kühe ruft war
früher sperrgebiet heute ist er hier bio
landwirt die bavaria ist sachsen und
dann beginnt bei schneider ist 1987 hier
geboren und immer geblieben sein
elternhaus war das letzte in der ddr wie
er sagt jetzt ist gras über die grenze
gewachsen das grüne band legt sich über
die zeit der teilung im dreiländereck
zwischen sachsen thüringen und bayern am
3 freistaaten stein treffen sie
aufeinander
hier leben sie mittlerweile miteinander
das geben und nehmen im dreiländereck
begann mit langen schlangen ins
bayerische hof das damals selbst am
fördertopf fing durch den eisernen
vorhang brachen hier im zonenrandgebiet
absatzmärkte weg und arbeitsplätze auch
im holzhandel von familie saalfrank in
hof gegründet 1924 vor der wende hatten
sie nur noch 20 mitarbeiter danach
hatten viele anfangs sorge was es heißt
wenn die zonenrandförderung wegbricht
doch marina saalfrank hat wie viele von
den neuen absatzmärkten profitiert
nicht das was heute hat die firma 110
mitarbeiter marina saalfrank nimmt uns
mit ins sächsische plauen hier haben sie
eine zweigstelle eine holzwerkstatt die
belegschaft kommt aus bayern thüringen
und sachsen
auf jeden fall hier in der region
geschaffen haben wir auch für ddr zeiten
relativ am ende es ist wirklich richtig
gut dass im endeffekt auch die
bayerischen
investieren halten aber was halt immer
ein rennen das argument es ist natürlich
auch der verdienst also selbst wenn
schon 50 kilometer weiter war habe ich
die chance auf mehr verließen nicht
alles ist eins geworden was hier in
plauen im oktober 89 mit mut und
hoffnung begann die erste demonstration
die von der ddr volkspolizei nicht mehr
aufgelöst werden konnte darauf sind sie
stolz auf dem altmarkt sind heute
händler aus dem dreiländereck die
empfindet das so dass das so ist dass
die sich also wirklich als als region
als teile einer region empfinden und
nicht unbedingt dieses ost west inc wir
haben schon noch mal
ob wir die noch schaffen unsere
generation wahrscheinlich nicht auf
unsere nach kundschaft die nachkommen im
thüringischen bad lobenstein setzten
sich mit dem leben im ddr grenzgebiet
auseinander tim jasmin willi und chris
haben an ihrem gymnasium eine
ausstellung organisiert thema jugend in
der ddr und leute gesagt haben wurde er
auch damals viel mannschaftlicher
gewesen ist bei einem stärkeren
zusammenhalt als ritter irgendwie das
war es ja viel politischer geprägt war
halt alles so ein bisschen vor gestimmt
quasi indirekt pflicht ohne
vergangenheit keine zukunft ohne
auseinandersetzung damit auch nicht
besonders wichtig es ist unsere schüler
zu selbstbewussten jungen menschen zu
erziehen die schüler sollten sich auch
mit unterschiedlichen auffassungen
auseinander setzen um ein eigenes
geschichtsbild zu entwickeln
das drei länder eck im wandel
die grenze ist geschichte das
zusammenwachsen bleibt auch in zukunft
eine aufgabe
und seit 1997 ist der tag der deutschen
einheit immer auch tag der offenen
moschee und damit beginnt die
nachrichten von 1 12 zum
fünfundzwanzigsten tag der offenen
moschee hatten heute bundesweit rund
1000 muslimische gemeinden eingeladen
bundespräsident steinmeier schrieb in
einem grußwort der tag der offenen
moschee sei ein wichtiges zeichen um den
tag täglich gelebten islam der in
unserem land zu hause sei sichtbar zu
machen in diesem jahr stand der tag
unter dem motto moscheen gestern und
heute zehntausende interessierte kamen
zu den teilnehmenden moscheegemeinden
die etwa zu gesprächen führungen und
workshops einluden
ein internationaler recherche verbund
hat nach eigenen angaben erneut brisante
dokumente über das finanzgebaren
hunderte politiker und andere prominente
aus aller welt zugespielt bekommen und
die unterlagen ausgewertet nach ersten
bekanntgewordenen ergebnissen sollen sie
auf 35 amtierende und frühere
staatenlenker betreffen etwas 12
millionen dokumenten sollen die
sogenannten pandora papers demnach eines
der bislang größten datenlecks zu
geschäften den steueroasen seien
beim absturz eines kleinflugzeuges am
stadtrand von mailand sind alle acht
insassen in der maschine ums leben
gekommen italienische medien berichten
von mindestens einem deutschen
todesopfer eine offizielle bestätigung
gibt es dafür noch nicht ziel des
flugzeugs war die insel sardinien aber
bereits wenige minuten nach dem start
stürzte die chartermaschine in ein leer
stehendes bürogebäude und fing feuer die
ursache des unglücks ist bislang
unbekannt die italienische
flugsicherheitsbehörde ermittelt zu dem
vorfall
in mehreren brasilianischen städten
haben zehntausende gegen präsident
personal protestiert unter anderem wegen
seines umgangs mit der korona pandemie
gewerkschaften und soziale bewegungen
hatten gut ein jahr vor der nächsten
präsidentschaftswahl zu den protesten
aufgerufen
neben einer besseren versorgung mit
impfstoffen forderten die
demonstrierenden auch eine amtsenthebung
gold solar er lehnte schutzmaßnahmen in
der vergangenheit immer wieder ab und
äußerte sich skeptisch gegenüber
impfungen
in den usa sind in diesem sommer
innerhalb eines monats fünf prominente
talk moderatorin an corona gestorben sie
waren in ihrem radiosendungen als
radikale impfgegner aufgetreten und
hatten die gefährlichkeit des virus
kleingeredet von einem der fünf wird
berichtet dass er das auf dem sterbebett
dann bitter bereut haben soll doch eine
solche erkenntnis ist keineswegs
selbstverständlich auch in deutschen
kliniken machen ärzte und pflegepersonal
die erstaunliche erfahrung des selbst
schwerstkranke patienten immer noch
behaupten sie hätten kein corona das
gab's gar nicht solche fälle häufen sich
inzwischen weil auf den kurs stationen
fast nur noch ungeimpfte legen die
meisten mittleren alters beispiel
rosenheim die impfquote im landkreis ist
und vom bundesdurchschnitt die inzidenz
hoch sie liegt war über 200
erschöpft sind sie in den kliniken hier
schon lange durch die pandemie wellen
und aufgeschobene behandlungen ist
praktisch nie pause sibylle bassler
berichtet
dass romed klinikum in rosenheim über
2000 kobe patienten wurden hier
behandelt 400 davon auf der
intensivstation
versorgt von ärzten wie karl ziegler und
die pflege team was ein halt besonders
belastet ist mittlerweile hätte man die
chance gehabt durchimpfung diese vierte
welle zu verhindern und das ist nicht
geschehen sechs schwer kranke sind
aktueller für intensiv menschen zwischen
38 und 60 jahren bis auf einen sind alle
umgehen wie dieser mann er kämpft um
sein leben zerstört wird er umgelagert
schwerstarbeit doch es sei nicht die
arbeit die nur gemacht
nebenan eine patientin die seit tagen
endlich über den berg ist sie möchte
nicht zu erkennen seien es muss wirklich
ganz schlimm um mich gestanden haben
also das überlegt wurde ob man mich ins
künstliche koma liegt künstliche
beatmung intubieren alles mögliche es
muss sehr kritisch gewesen sein selbst
zwar keine corona läuferin hatte sie
sich jedoch nicht impfen lassen weil ich
dem impfstoff noch nicht vertraue aber
ich würde diese entscheidung obwohl ich
hier jetzt schon seit über einer woche
liege da hat sich an meiner meinung
nichts geändert ich würde mich nach wie
vor nicht impfen lassen ob denn ihre
familie geimpft ist nein kein mensch auf
ein 86 jähriger vater nicht
momente wie diese sind es die es dem
team schwer machen ruhig zu bleiben sich
auf ihre arbeit zu konzentrieren
es habe auch schon anfeindungen gegeben
sagt der arzt verbale vereinzelt auch
körperliche mit angehörigen aber auch
mit patienten
ist natürlich vollkommen überflüssig
dann auch noch seine zeit mit so einen
unsinn zu verbringen wenn man ohnehin
schon genug zu tun hat corona leugner
und impfverweigerer das verhalten
mancher menschen ärgere auch ihn
zunehmend zu der geschäftsführer der
klinik denn es geht zu lasten seines
teams das längst schon an der
belastungsgrenze seiten ich glaube wir
sind an einem punkt angekommen wo wir
eine impfpflicht brauchen weil zu viel
auf dem spiel steht und bei die
situation für meine kolleginnen und
kollegen unerträglich ist vor der
intensivstation wartet ein neuer coup
patient auch er ungeimpft und wieder
werden sie alles tun um dem schwer
kranken zu helfen so oberarzt eklat denn
schließlich sei es ihr job
und jetzt nochmal weitere nachrichten
hat die beiden deutschen tischtennis
teams haben bei der europameisterschaft
in rumänien gold gewonnen erst holten
sich die frauen im finale den sieg gegen
gastgeber und titelverteidiger rumänien
und danach gelang das gleiche den
männern gegen russland
in der fußball bundesliga gab es heute
drei spiele mit drei heimniederlagen
mainz union berlin 1 2 bayern münchen
eintracht frankfurt 1 2 und arminia
bielefeld bayer leverkusen 0 zu 4
und noch zum wetter die aussichten für
morgen in einem breiten streifen vom
schwarzwald bis zur oder dichte wolken
und zeitweise regen sonst trocken und
vor allem im nordwesten längerem
sonnenschein höchstwerte 13 bis 20 grad
und die weiteren aussichten auch am
dienstag und mittwoch sehr wechselhaft
und häufig regen ab donnerstag
wetterberuhigung wenig
temperaturänderung das war es von uns
weiter geht's gleich mit den oakland
detektivs und um 0.25 gibt's die nächste
heute express und hier werden sie morgen
abend von christian sievers und kaiser
richter erwartet auf wiedersehen wieder
sinn
[Musik]